[Música]
a ver las noches me da muchísimo gusto
verlos aquí sé que es una noche fría
pero vamos a dar un poquito de calor con
este tema el día de hoy voy a hablar
sobre cómo eliges es una pregunta amplia
que seguramente muchos de ustedes no se
han detenido tal vez ha pensado en una
vez todo el tiempo estamos tomando
decisiones desde que te levantas si te
vas a despertar cinco minutos antes o si
te vas a echar una pestaña para dormir
unos minutitos más
también si vas a ir a trabajar o mejor
te vas a reportar enfermo si decides o
no poner a lo cual ropa todo el tiempo
todo el día las tomando decisiones y
decidir es un proceso que pareciera
siempre cognitivo como si siempre
tuvieras que preguntarte una razón para
elegir si esto es positivo o es negativo
para mí como lo voy a decidir
hay algunos que se han preguntado si el
recibir está meramente basado en los
temas cognitivos o en los temas
desde la razón sin embargo nos hemos
venido dando cuenta con el tiempo que
muchas de estas elecciones no tienen que
ver con la razón sino con tus emociones
muchas veces eliges desde la emoción y a
veces eliges bien también otra de las de
los fundamentos de las elecciones es
justamente lo que nos enseña
cuando eres niño aprendes a elegir o más
bien tus papás eligen por ti
muchas veces toman decisiones ellos
desde su historia desde sus influencias
desde sus necesidades nos cuesta mucho
trabajo como papás ahora que yo soy
madre entender este niño o esta niña
también tiene una forma de pensar y una
forma de ver la vida lógicamente habrá
decisiones muy fundamentales que
nosotros como padres tomamos por ellos
lo que tendremos que poco a poco ir
soltando
la capacidad para que ellos puedan crear
sus propias decisiones y sus propias
elecciones
antes de poder definir qué es lo que
deciden estos padres e hijos bien es
importante identificar que muchas de
estas veces cuando elegimos tenemos que
decisión que tener encuentra 13 eres una
es que siempre que tomas una decisión
vas a tener un riesgo que quiere decir
en el momento que eliges entre dos o
tres o diez alternativas regularmente
estás tomando un riesgo de tener una
buena decisión y es cierto a veces
pendientes tomas el riesgo de que no sea
una buena decisión hay decisiones que
has tomado que tienes no te han gustado
lo que ha resultado de ellas algo que
también es 100% seguro cuando estás
eligiendo es que vas a tener una
renuncia es justamente lo que dificulta
las elecciones el poder decir pues bueno
es que me quedo con el novio guapo pero
no tiene dinero
o me quedo con este trabajo que me
brinda un buen salario que no me da una
satisfacción o me quedo en esta
situación de conflicto con mi amiga para
evitarme un problema o en esta situación
de pareja para evitarme un conflicto no
hay que tener claro que cuando tomamos
decisiones o cuando elegimos siempre
siempre vas a tener que renunciar a algo
y bueno
para la responsabilidad porque cuando
eliges algo tendrás que tomar
responsabilidad sobre eso que eliges
hacerte cargo de que eso que estás
eligiendo pues tendrá una consecuencia
regularmente ojalá que sea positiva
además no solamente elegimos desde la
historia sino también desde nuestro
género ser mujer te ponen en medio justo
de una situación para elegir ciertas
cosas y ser hombre en otras por ejemplo
las mujeres tenemos que decidir si
queremos o no una carrera profesional si
queremos o no ser madres
si queremos además combinar ambas cosas
y esto se convierte también en un
conflicto muchas veces para que les
tienen que decidirlo
para los hombres las elecciones también
son complejas los hombres tienen que
elegir también el sentir o no sentir que
se les ha dictado desde su género que no
deben llorar que no deben de prestar
muchas de sus emociones y entiendo que
esto ha venido cambio
tenemos una brecha importante por
trabajar
cuando elegimos hay que preguntarnos hay
que cuestionarnos porque a veces
pareciera que solamente vamos por la
vida como se nos vaya presentando y
elegimos en función más bien de lo que
el contexto nos va dotando o nos está
brindando
este es un ice ver lo que alcanzamos a
ver pues en la punta en realidad nuestra
forma de pensar funciona la parte
consciente es esa pequeña parte que está
arriba y la parte que siente que esto
esa parte que se ve hacia abajo es el
hielo que está abajo esa parte
inconsciente que te quiero decir muchas
veces más
desde esta parte inconsciente
se mueven otras cosas que tú no conoces
para elegir
te preguntas por qué si esto aparece no
tiene nada que ver conmigo porque elegí
este trabajo o porque elegí estar en
este lugar y al final te das cuenta que
muchas de esas elecciones
también contacto sin explicación tanto
inconscientes
al elegir de esta forma es cierto veces
vamos a encontrarnos con esta la culpa
cuando tomas una elección que no fue la
mejor o que tu criterio no fue la mejor
viene este sentimiento este esta emoción
que yo pienso que es una de las
emociones los más desagradables y que no
son útiles para el ser humano
una cosa sentir responsabilidad sobre lo
que haces y otra muy diferente sentirte
culpable por ello que por lo que hiciste
la culpa casi siempre es una tiene una
función de detener de sostener no de
avanzar lo que hace es decirte
remarcando que lo hiciste mal
derecho como lo hiciste entonces cuando
tienes esta función en realidad yo te
diría está instalado si solamente te va
a funcionar para quedarte ahí desecharla
y mejor convierten en responsabilidad y
hazte cargo de ello
para esto debemos entonces queda
deformar las creencias y esto es
complejísimo
todos los que te dijeron que estaba bien
el más cuestionado
todo lo que tus padres te heredaron que
necesitabas saber para decidir será real
a una tarea del ser humano indispensable
es justamente cuestionarnos
y es una tarea que no es tratado ahora
para los padres sino más bien para poder
crecer
entre menos certezas tengas entre menos
verdades claras tengas para poder dudar
dudar siempre te va a hacer crecer
preguntarte qué hago aquí para qué por
qué elijo esto y no en aquello siempre
te va a hacer crecer ante esa
oportunidad de aprender
claro puedes describir porque ahora
quienes digan pues bueno yo he elegido
bien todas las selecciones de mi vida de
las rodillas
cierto solo escribiste en un papel
cuando decidiste embargo también tienes
la capacidad de borrarlo y por supuesto
no se van a ir las marcas pero puedes
reescribir sobre ese mismo papel y darle
un sentido diferente a tu elección
te voy a invitar a hacer un ejercicio
bien breve yo sé que el sonido no nos
está ayudando mucho pero vamos a
intentarlo cerramos los ojos por favor
te pido que si eres
todas aquellas decisiones
qué te ha costado tomar
se te ha pagado elegir
acá son muchas
diría que elijas aquella aquella
decisión
qué te hizo sentir en algún momento
elegirse mal que es una mala decisión
que fue una mala elección
aquella decisión que tal vez con el
tiempo has intentado borrar él piensa
quién eras en ese momento
colega tu contexto los gustos tus
necesidades
por qué elegiste cómo elegiste
estoy segura de que no eras el mismo ni
la misma que eres hoy
hoy que juzgas esta elección como mala
como negativa
date la oportunidad de entender y de ser
un poco más
comprensivo comprensiva contigo mismo
para entender que en ese entonces no
eras quien eres hoy
y probablemente en ese entonces será la
elección que toca va a tomar
que si en algún punto te has sentido
culpable por esta elección te permita
poder reescribir nuevamente esa historia
o conciliar la si tienes que pedir un
perdón no si es para ti ese perdón te
invito a que también lo hagas
y en el momento que tú quieras puedes
abrir tus ojos para incorporarte aquí y
recordar que tú tienes la capacidad de
reescribir tu historia
la vida tu vida arriésgate gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]